but then here's where things get
interesting
28 of millennials almost one out of
three millennials aged 26 to 40
say their parents still are giving them
some form
of financial support so this past year
get this jenny i want to get your
thoughts on this 52 percent more than
half of millennials were still living in
their parents
home this is the highest number ever it
surpassed the previous record which was
a freaking during world war ii in 1940
148 of young adults lived with their
parents i'm going to throw a couple
stats out there and then we're going to
weigh in on this topic real quick okay
so overall 55 percent of americans say
their parents have helped them
financially at some point during
adulthood so that's over 50
that includes things like paying for
college understandable but then you get
into things like living at home rent
free
um
buying them a car that's 16 and then
minor things like paying for their cell
phone bill or even
car insurance the average amount that
the parents are giving their adult
children is 4 200
4 200 a year i almost choked up a little
bit jenny okay
so on the flip side 21 of americans
currently provide financial support for
their parents i'm in that category i
help my mama out so this is me so bottom
line is
for a lot of you young adults out there
thank god for the bank of mom and dad so
here's where i'm going to open it up to
the lovely ladies and jenny i'm gonna
start with you be honest yes when did
your parents cut you off financially or
are your parents still helping you out
at all right now so my parents did help
me a lot financially growing up right
okay yeah um i'm a professional i was a
professional dancer so i was touring the
world with different artists i wasn't
home a lot
so for me i didn't find it reasonable to
be renting an apartment that i'm not
going to be in okay with that being said
my parents allowed me to live rent free
and save
my dollars
my mom's an accountant all right that's
why i'm really big with financing
because i believe that you need to save
your money
use it wisely like still have your fun i
don't need everything sitting in the
bank account however i was somebody that
i didn't i never wanted to rent i wanted
to buy okay so at the age of 25 i left
and i bought myself a place in miami in
miami
it was my biggest investment someone
said by the way you hit it before
everyone started moving to miami yes
which was which was crazy right because
kovit just hit and i was like
uh now i'm sitting at home and i'm not
working oh my god okay so you're i don't
want to put your stuff out there but
you're 20 i'm five oh twenty seven
twenty five yes and currently are your
parents helping you out at all right now
my car they help you with your car my
dad's a car so when you read these stats
or you're like a little offended or
you're like no no i mean i i think i
think i think
it's it depends on the situation do you
know what i mean like you were on the
road it made no sense to have a friend
right and my dad's a car do that's why i
don't pay my card you know so it depends
on the situation now i i do think
parents need to find leeway and have
their kids put in the work like some
kids are sitting at home like playing
video games eating chips like but if you
see your kid putting in the work some
kids are visionaries and they have they
have this dream of being an entrepreneur
and creating this stuff and right now
they're focused on that and parents are
supporting that and i agree with parents
supporting their kids vision
however i don't believe that they should
be just
without any responsibilities living rent
free there has to be an age gap i mean i
don't i mean 30 still living at home
that's a little bit
i'm going to actually get back to that
nancy
do your do your parents still help you
out financially
no my parents actually never really gave
me money but the thing is i lived at
home for like up until i was 24. okay so
as far as helping me out it was just me
not paying rent or paying anything
gotcha so you paid no rent when you
lived at home no did how did you
contribute to your family's well-being
like did you do chores did you
assist on anything did you pay the
utilities what were you doing
so it's weird because um i lived in my
brother and sister actually okay so not
your parents you're saying no
yeah no my i moved in with my sister she
ended up buying a big house and then her
and my brother shared it so i just lived
there and they would ask for rent but i
would never give it and it was just it
was just that who would ask for rent you
would never give up my sister but it was
out of spite
like she was like hey give me money i'm
like okay and then make money give me a
money you're like like that was how i
was living with my sister for like every
month it was just
her asking money for me and my brother
just to i mean she could definitely
afford it here's my question for you
though okay so
everyone has it's situational everyone
everyone has reasons like you were you
were traveling i get it you know you
were living with your sister but here's
my question for you what is an
acceptable age
to basically get cut off from your
parents meaning like okay 24 you're
traveling okay 26 all right put it still
at 30. because millennials are are in
their late 30s now what's an acceptable
age or an appropriate age for your
parents to say you're done they were not
giving you another freaking penny what
do you think
whatever the dating age is what does
that mean as in like if you're 21 and
then you're trying to take someone out
like it is a little off-putting if
they're still living at home right like
for me like i wouldn't date anybody that
was still living at home while i'm
living alone so some dude takes you out
he's like listen we're going to go out
to have a nice dinner we're going to
have a good time and then we're going to
go back to my parents place and get it
home you're not into that no not really
jenny
any as a guy ever tried to take you back
to his parents place since you know
you've been 21 plus
since 21 plus no but i've dated men who
are successful
what does that mean
i'm just saying poor not oh gotcha
you're saying you're like you're like no
i don't date broke dudes
[Music]